qué sabe usted de la retirada de
credenciales a cinco periodistas de efe
porque sólo se les regresó a dos de
ellos la autorización
bueno tan incomprensible como la
decisión que tomó el gobierno de
retirarse las así como de no habilitar
las credenciales del jefe de la oficina
de la agencia en la habana creo que es
simplemente una estrategia de
amedrentamiento de control de la
información lo que se busca
viendo que llegaba el día de la
manifestación era generar ese clima de
autocensura de impedir la movilización
en el
desplazamiento de los periodistas para
que cubran las jornadas lo mismo le ha
pasado nuestro vicepresidente regional
en la isla y konstantín en pocos días
antes fue citado para una
presentarse en la oficina para
verificar sus
acciones en redes sociales y seguramente
en las próximas días va a recibir una
multa pero además en su domicilio
particular hay apostados en ambas
esquinas una en cada lado personal que
está controlando sus desplazamientos y
verificando qué tareas realiza para la
cobertura de la manifestación esta
ocurre con todos los manifestantes con
todos los periodistas con todos los
dirigentes sociales que están
movilizándose en esta jornada por el
reclamo de libertad y por reclamos de
cambios del aire bueno entendiendo eso
que puede decirnos sobre el cubrimiento
periodístico en la isla cómo es ejercer
el periodismo bajo el manto del
comunismo castrista
pero realmente es muy muy complejo hace
mucho tiempo que empezó a ver este clima
de amedrentamiento
sobre todo con la asunción del nuevo
presidente el día está en el se acentó
la reflexión el clima de censura y
en las dos manifestaciones que ha habido
la del 11 de julio y está convocada para
hoy quedan realizados en este total el
clima de asfixia de ahogo informativo es
como decíamos se quiere tapar el sol con
un armero porque realmente el gobierno
no está viendo esta movilización social
expresa un cambio en la isla un cambio
en la búsqueda de mayor libertad de
mayor apertura política de la
posibilidad de debatir los reales
problemas que está teniendo la vista
problemas en lo económico problema en lo
sanitario y también problemas en la
relación del gobierno con la ciudadanía
esta decisión de piel ya está en el de
llamar a defender la revolución lo que
busca es defender un statu quo pero no
los principios que la gente está
reclamando que es una posibilidad de una
mayor apertura política